Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is at a
conference in Paris today with tech
leaders discussing their global
influence the appearance comes as
Facebook and others face growing
questions about users data and privacy
European lawmakers grilled Zuckerberg
yesterday in Brussels he apologized for
his company's mistakes Mark Phillips is
in London mark good morning good morning
well it's the latest leg of the great
Facebook apology tour but neither the
performance of Mark Zuckerberg or of his
European Union questioners is getting
much in the way of likes this morning if
the intent of Mark Zuckerberg appearance
in Brussels was to hold the Facebook
founders feet to the fire the fire
wasn't very hot the problem was the
format the EU parliamentarians decided
to ask all their questions at once
how can non users stop Facebook
collecting their data they went on for
about an hour especially if people want
to come off Facebook how quickly and
under what conditions will their data be
fully removed Zuckerberg could just
listen and look contrite is Cambridge
analytic an isolated case when the time
came for answers there was very little
of it left
and the responses were general and
familiar we didn't take a broad enough
view of our responsibility and that was
a mistake and I'm sorry for it the
European Union is about to implement its
general data protection regulations
which in theory protect personal data by
default require clear consent for
personal information to be collected
include the right to be forgotten if
users want their information deleted and
provide for enforcement finds Mark
Zuckerberg escaped to Z you encounter
relatively unscathed but with a question
hanging in the air you have to ask
yourself well how you will be remembered
as one of the three big Internet giants
together with Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
where are the other hands the genius who
created a digital monster that is
destroying all democracies as for those
unanswered questions occur Berg said
he'd get back to them European data
protection rules go into effect this
Friday and provide
for fines as high as four percent of
annual global revenues in Facebook's
case that could run into the billions
Gail all right mark Philips reporting
from London thank you very much
interesting format isn't it guys ask all
the questions then he can kind of decide
which ones I'm going to answer and then
say I'll get back to you on that
interesting but maybe not that effective
that's right